[Applaus]
[Musik]
stell dir vor du müsstest nach einem
land ausschau halten indem du dein geld
langfristig anlegen könntest ich würde
jede wette eingehen dass dir dabei ein
bestimmtes land nicht mal im traum in
den sinn käme venezuela nun liebe
freunde von visual politik chinas
regierung ist in dieser sache ganz
anderer meinung
china sagt venezuela investitionen von
20 milliarden dollar zu um die
auswirkungen des ölpreisverfalls
auszugleichen
was jetzt aber mal lud auch denn china
ist nicht alleine beim investieren in
venezuela
es ist sogar ein fenster gesellschaft
habt ihr schon mal was von goldman sachs
gehört ja
ist das nicht eine jener banken die für
viele den amerikanischen kapitalismus in
reinkultur verkörpert genau die ist es
und goldman sachs scheint ebenfalls
ausgezeichnet investitionsgelegenheiten
in venezuela entdeckt zu haben
grothmann sex verursacht mit dem kauf
venezolanische anleihen im wert von 2,8
milliarden us dollar einen aufschrei ja
du hast dich nicht verhört während
venezuela eine der schlimmsten
wirtschaftlichen katastrophen der
menschheitsgeschichte überhaupt
durchlebt laufen die geschäfte mit den
grössten globalen investoren munter
weiter aus diesem grund kann der
venezolanische präsident nicolas maduro
trotz aller knappheit der extremen armut
und der hyperinflation hoch moderne
waffensysteme einkaufen um eine armee zu
unterhalten
die von so gut wie niemanden angegriffen
werden kann
eine armee die gerade über 5000 raketen
in russland produzieren lässt
im oktober 2017 traf sich meadows erneut
mit wladimir putin um neue waffen
geschäfte abzuschließen
mittlerweile ist traditionell auch der
größte tag nach china in der region
sie haben weit mehr chinesisches geld
erhalten als jedes andere
lateinamerikanische land nun für aktuell
vielleicht was steckt wir den ganzen
wenn es um geld geht sind china doch
ideologische feinheiten normalerweise
vollkommen schnuppe
das gleiche gilt ja auch für die
amerikanischen banken ihr einziges ziel
ist das geld zu verdienen und auf den
ersten blick sieht wenn die schüler
nicht gerade danach aus ein geeigneter
ort für gute geschäfte sein
wie also konnte venezuela hat die
aufmerksamkeit so viele internationale
investoren gewinnen heute werden wir
euch alle diese fragen beantworten aber
bevor wir dies tun
lasst uns wie immer einen blick in die
geschichte
[Musik]
eine riskante wette kleiner tipp am
rande wenn du jemals mit dem gedanken
spielen sollte es diktator eines landes
zu werden die opposition brutal zu
unterdrücken und politische gegner zu
foltern brauchst du dazu vor allem eines
viel geld
[Musik]
denn den ein paar bürger kannst du ruhig
hungern und vor die hunde gehen lassen
aber da einen polizeikräften und den
armeeangehörigen darfst du keinen
einzigen zahltag passen die größte
bedrohung für einen autoritären führer
wie nicolas maduro besteht darin dass
die armee gegen ihn resultieren könnte
falls du wieso alle politik schon länger
schaust weißt du sicher das ist in
venezuela so gut wie keine privaten
unternehmen mehr gibt es gibt also nicht
besonders viel geld das motto in form
von steuern einsam mutante darüber
hinaus sind ölexporte nicht mehr
besonders rentabel da die ölpreise im
jahre 2012 eingebrochen sind
[Musik]
mit anderen worten der einzige weg um
seinen gewaltigen unterdrückungsapparats
am laufen zu halten besteht darin
kredite auf dem internationalen markt
einzusammeln
moment mal sagst du jetzt eine
derartiges unterfangen dürfte einem land
mit so gewaltigen wirtschaftlichen
problemen wie venezuela
doch verdammt schwer fallen denn das
risiko sein einmal an venezuela
verliehenes geld wiederzusehen muss doch
unglaublich hoch sein
aus diesem grund sagen wir dass der
islamische anleihen eine hochriskante
anlagen darstellen
[Applaus]
aber was tun länder wenn investoren
ihnen nicht vertrauen nur sie erhöhen
den zinssatz und deswegen bekommt man
auch venezolanische staatsanleihen eine
rendite von mehr als zehn bis zwölf
prozent ok aber was bedeutet das nun
konkret nun stell dir vor wir
investieren 1.000 us dollar ein bei der
solar mission staatsanleihen die in zehn
jahren fällig werden und mit zehn
prozent verzinst sind
theoretisch können wir von der
brasilianischen regierung erwarten dass
sie uns die 1000 dollar die wir ihnen
geliehen haben in zehn jahren
zurückzahlt und in der zwischenzeit
erhalten wir noch jedes jahr 100 dollar
als zinszahlung
[Applaus]
ich weiß was du denkst das klingt doch
wie ein gutes geschäft nicht wahr
nun wollte ich nicht so früh wie bereits
gesagt ist das pleiterisiko venezuela
ist recht hoch wenn die regierung in
caracas der hauptstadt venezuelas in den
nächsten zwei jahren insolvenz anmelden
würde
hättet ihr 80 prozent ihrer
investitionen verloren
aus diesem grunde viel ist trotz der
hohen zinsen nicolás maduro immer
schwerer seine anleihen an den mann zu
bringen
dies erklärt dann nachrichten die
folgende ankauf von venezuela anleihen
durch goldman sachs sorgt für wut es
kaufte anleihen im wert von 2,8
milliarden us dollar für rund 865
millionen us dollar
okay okay was bedeutet das nun es
bedeutet dass goldman sachs
elektronische anleihen für ein drittel
ihres wertes gekauft hat mit anderen
worten
theoretisch wird von der venezolanischen
regierung erwartet dass die nach ablauf
der anleihen 2,8 milliarden us dollar an
goldman sex zurückzahlen obwohl die bahn
nur 865 millionen us dollar dafür
bezahlt hat und warum akzeptiert
venezuela diesen deal nun zum einen
brauchen sie das geld so schnell wie
möglich zum anderen wissen sie ganz
genau dass es in wirklichkeit nie
zurückgezahlt wird
tja und jetzt fragt ihr euch wiederum
warum verleihen die banker so viel geld
wenn jedermann weiß dass venezuela es
nicht zurückzahlen wird die wollen doch
kein geld verlieren sondern verdienen
das ist deren geschäft ja das tun sie
auch uns war mit den zinsen wenn
venezuela goldman sachs jedes jahr zehn
prozent von diesen 2,8 milliarden an
zinsen zahlt bedeutet dies dass ich für
die bank jene tatsächlich
investitionssumme von 865 millionen us
dollar
in weniger als drei jahren amortisiert
alles weitere ist reine gewinn
die anleger wissen also dass wenn jetzt
wieder pleite gehen wird nur wissen sie
nicht genau wann und genau darin besteht
die wette sollte wenn die zuhörer
mindestens vier jahre hat durchhalten
gewesen die banken falls nicht verlieren
sie die wette und er war chancen so
gewinnen standen gar nicht mal so
schlecht denn nikolaus war duo ist der
allerletzte der sein land für bankrott
erklären möchte er muss nämlich
einerseits die banker bei laune halten
damit diese weiter seine unterdrückung
maschine refinanzieren und andererseits
verfügt wenn es wie das staatliche
ölgesellschaft pdv usa über so einiges
vermögen im ausland
es geht um fabriken und raffinerien in
ländern wie haiti und der
dominikanischen republik die alle
blitzschnell gepfändet werden könnten
falls caracas den rhythmus fall aussieht
[Musik]
aus diesem grund kommt venezuela seine
schuldenzahlungen schon seit jahren
absoluten vorrang ein auch wenn das
tafelsilber verfrühstückt wird die
fremdwährungsreserven marco russ vielen
den auch von über 50 milliarden us
dollar auf weniger als zehn milliarden
dies erklärt warum ein magazin wie
forbes noch im jahr 2016 folgendes über
venezolanische allein schrieb
venezuela ist vielleicht das übelste
land in lateinamerika aber deren
anleihen sind großartig aus donald trump
war es schließlich der zur jahresmitte
2017 ein gesetz einbringen musste das
amerikanischen banken und hedgefonds er
bietet in venezuela zu investieren und
so sehr sich maduro nun anstrengen
seine position war nun noch schwächer
als er es gedacht hätte
venezuela muss seine auslands kredite
umschulden totalausfall erscheint
möglich ja du hast richtig gehört
sex und die anderen hedgefonds die
dachten sie hätten venezolanische
anleihen zu einem schnäppchenpreis
ergattert haben ihre wette verloren was
euch jetzt aber nicht zu sehr von ihrer
schadenfreude mitreißen
denn es gibt noch immer einen investor
der weit davon entfernt ist sich sorgen
machen zu müssen
genau wir sprechen über chinas
marionette wie wir schon zu beginn
erwähnt haben hat von allen ländern
lateinamerikas gerade venezuela
die meisten chinesischen investitionen
erhalten im gegensatz zu den
privatbanken kauft die chinesische
regierung keine anleihen auf dem freien
markt stattdessen traf sich in
persönlich mit nicolás maduro
dabei wurde ein sonderangebot
ausgehandelt ein darlehen das nicht mit
geld sondern mit erdöl zurückgezahlt
werden soll
[Musik]
auf diese weise sichert sich peking
öllieferungen egal was passiert ihr
müsst euch es aber vorstellen dass wir
hier nicht von politessen reden was
glaubt ihr welches land der erde über
die größten nachgewiesenen ölreserven
verfügt jetzt einfach mal ist es saudi
arabien der iran oder irak qradar
russland oder die usa
alles falsch venezuela ist mit abstand
die nummer eins
[Musik]
alles in butter also da kann nichts
schief gehen oder
nun wieder einmal ist es nicht ganz so
einfach
die staatliche ölgesellschaft des
wählers pdv usa ist ein hyper
bürokratischer moloch in dem
abertausende nicht liegen ihrer
besonderen kompetenzen dem öl business
beschäftigt sind sondern weil sie der
ehemalige präsident chávez für ihre
treue zu ihm
mit vielen vielen lukrativen löschen
lohnt hat und das macht das bohren nach
öl nicht gerade einfach
in letzter zeit kommen die dinos auf
lieferungen aus venezuela mit immer
grösserer verspätung nach china
trotz all dem hält china an venezuela
fest wir bekunden unsere solidarität mit
dem venezolanischen volk weil wir die
prinzipien der vereinten nationen
unterstützen
das ist stellt sich also die frage warum
china das alles mitmacht wo ist nun
offensichtlich problem mit den öligen
gibt weil china sehr langfristig denkt
überlegt einfach mal peking hat caracas
bereits 50 milliarden dollar geliehen
und jetzt müssen sie noch geduld haben
und stabilität maduro braucht noch ein
paar jahre mehr um seine schulden
zurückzahlen
china hat keine eile jinping kann warten
eine sache könnte die rückzahlung der
schulden jedoch gefährden einen wechsel
[Musik]
ron konermann der maduro stürzen will am
23 januar 2009 10 legte ein wenig
bekannter venezolanischer parlamentarier
den amtseid ab und erklärte sich vor
einer menge jubelnder anhänger im
zentrum von caracas tun in paris
in einer mitreißenden rede argumentierte
er dass die wiederwahl von präsident
nicolas maduro unrechtmäßig verlief um
das präsidentenamt eigentlich vakant sei
mit der verfassung in der hand sagte er
dass es nun an ihm als sprecher der
nationalversammlung der einzigen von der
opposition kontrollierte institution
liege das land aus der wirtschaftlichen
und politischen krisen herauszuführen er
wurde von den usa
wenn jetzt will das nachbarland
brasilien und kolumbien und ihren
anderen lateinamerikanischen ländern
schnell als legitimer führer anerkannt
die liste der länder die sich auf die
seite des jungen gesetzgeber stellten
wuchs bald auf mehr als 50 an
was würde passieren wenn die opposition
an die macht käme wäre sie bereit ihren
verpflichtungen gegenüber denen
nachzukommen die jenen diktator
unterstützt haben der sie ins gefängnis
geworfen und gefoltert hat es hört sich
ziemlich riskant an nicht wahr und
risiko ist genau jenes wort das die
kommunistische partei chinas am
allerwenigsten mag
und dies würde schlagzeilen wie die
folgende erklären
venezuela verteidigt den kauf
chinesischer ausrüstung für
aufstandsbekämpfung nach mehr als 70
toten bei straßenprotesten china hat
bereits waffen im wert von über 350
millionen dollar an maduro verkauft
damit er an der macht bleiben kann
deswegen ist caracas chinas größter
verbündeter in der regierung im grunde
macht die chinesische kp damit die
venezolanische regierung zu ihrer
marionette
china wird die zukunft bestimmen es gibt
eine reihe von gründen warum peking
trotz finanzieller einbußen weiterhin
hinter der regierung marco russ steht
als sich der von den usa unterstützte
oppositionsführer angebotsvo
interimspräsidenten venezuela erklärte
dachte er das ist einfach wäre nicolás
maduro abzusetzen
china aber weigert er sich die
präsidentschaft groß anzuerkennen mit
der begründung dass dies eine
einmischung in innere angelegenheiten
eines souveränen staates gleichkäme
china betrachtet das ölreiche
sozialistische land als einen
bedeutenden handelspartner und einen
geopolitischen verbündeten im hinterhof
seines wichtigsten politischen und
wirtschaftlichen rivalen den usa darüber
hinaus haben die investitionen pekings
venezuela zu einem wichtigen bestandteil
der künftigen wirtschaftlichen
entwicklung und der energiesicherheit
chinas gemacht peking steht nach wie vor
an der seite matthäus weil für china ein
gleichgesinnter sozialistischer
verbündeter im hinterhof der usa
wichtiger ist als alle finanziellen
kosten die china durch eine anhaltende
krise in venezuela entstehen könnten
[Musik]
möchte ich jeder eventuelles südamerika
neue handels infrastruktur aufbauen um
das ambitionierte seine straßen projekt
auszuweiten kein problem wenn er zu
lange diplomaten unterstützten sie
bedingungslos
oder wie wäre es mit einer neuen
militärbasis in der region willkommen in
venezuela ein fingerschnippen und die
chinesischen streitkräfte können sich
auf tausende von quadratkilometern breit
machen
[Musik]
ihr könnt einfach keinen besseren
verbünden finden als denjenigen der euch
braucht um zu überleben
[Musik]
die zeller hofft dass kein anderes land
die fantastische seidenstraße initiative
chinas behindern wird
trotz all dem sind doch recht große
sorgen angebracht mit so viel macht
könnte ich ihnen auch ganz andere
reformen als bisher fordert venezuela
beispielsweise weiterhin probleme mit
seinen öllieferungen hat könnte sie
maduro zwingen unproduktive angestellte
der pdv usa zu feuern unfälle effizienz
zu sorgen
oder sie könnte die ganze ölförderung
auch ganz in die eigenen hände über den
[Musik]
wenn israel sich hat sich neue öl
investitionen aus china
die neue anlage soll durch das die nur
wenn sein joint venture betrieben werden
welches sich zu 49 prozent im besitz der
china national petroleum corporation
cnpc und zu 51 prozent im besitz von
venezuelas pcv usa befindet
es stellt sich also die frage könnte
venezuela das land mit den größten
ölreserven der welt zu einer kolonie
chinas werden glaubt ihr dass china die
ölvorkommen venezuela spenden schlag
namen annektieren wird und dann mit
hilfe seines hochgradig effizienten
organisation des apparats perfekt und
außerhalb jeglichen wettbewerbs
ausbeuten wird welche macht hätte ein
china mit einem derartig einmaligen
wettbewerbsvorteil und welche
auswirkungen könnte dies auf das globale
geopolitische machtgefüge haben
[Musik]
lasst uns bitte wissen was er darüber
denkt denn dafür haben wir unter dem
video einen luxuriös bequemen
kommentarbereich eingerichtet und denkt
daran dass wir jede woche brandneue
videos veröffentlichen klickt auch denkt
noch zum abonnieren und verpasst keinen
beitrag mehr
wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat gebt
uns einen like daumen und nimmer bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]